Julian,
did you just say that I would volunteer to take selfies with everybody?
Well,
you see how many people are in here,
you know,
I mean,
we're Google,
so we can be very efficient.
We can streamline this process.
How about if we take a selfie with one person and then green scheming and
everyone's space.
Okay.
We can do that for sure.
All of the people that we want to be in that Selfie,
right?
No,
I'm happy to take selfies.
I,
it's just,
I'm just razzing you.
Okay.
Thank you.
Some more if you want.
So how are you?
I'm great.
Yeah.
Are,
you know,
I'm a,
you said this already,
right?
I'm native San Franciscan,
so,
um,
it's great to come home and uh,
it's great for my mom to come home and do a play,
right?
Oh yeah,
that it,
it's not really a,
it's a big deal for my family,
kind of.
So I love it.
And I love this theater.
I've always loved this particular theater,
American Conservatory Theater Act,
and I,
uh,
so this is a really great kind of collaboration with them that allows me to have
this hometown experience.
And to do a play like this one that I really,
really believe a lot in this particular play.
Yeah.
So let's talk a little bit about more about the play.
Okay.
I got to see it on Wednesday.
It was fantastic.
Oh,
great.
Yeah.
Um,
but I'm hoping more people here and folks on the livestream would come to see
it.
So can you tell us a little bit about the show?
Uh,
yes.
Well,
Lauren,
uh,
yeah.
Is the playwright Lauren and he is also a native San Franciscan.
Yes.
If you know anything,
I mean,
there was a big article about her and the pink section on Sunday.
Um,
but very briefly,
she really writes a lot from her own experience in her own family and has
written two plays in fact that are inspired in one way or another by her father.
This particular play is inspired by the fact that her father played basketball
in Chinatown in the early seventies and was on the basketball team of kids from
China at San Francisco Chinatown that went to China to play exhibition games
throughout China.
And so she's written a play about a young,
um,
very enthusiastic,
Asian American boy in high school who like will's his way onto the team to go
play in China,
um,
and kind of have this kind of,
what's it like for an Asian American kid to go to China experience.
Um,
and there's a lot more to the play and it'll a lot more is revealed in the play.
But,
um,
the,
the play also centers around the relationship between two basketball coaches,
a Chinese basketball players and an American basketball coach.
And I played the Chinese basketball coach.
So that's it basically.
Okay.
Basically and also kind in its identity.
It's,
it's a,
it's a comedy with an a really strong emotional undercurrent,
which is very rare in plays to me.
I find the most successful plays,
plays that are,
are successfully funny and move you at the same time.
I did you find it that way?
I did,
yes.
And I find that Lauren's work in particular,
she just did King of these at SF playhouse,
which is also another story about Larry.
Yes.
Um,
but I really like her work because she does straddle humor and touching some
soft points about family relationships,
which I think is really heartwarming about her work.
Yeah.
He's really skilled in that and the extra added,
I mean,
I really,
I'm here to sell tickets,
right,
of course.
But please for the really,
really sincerely recommend this experience of seeing this play in San Francisco
and also it's too late to see king of the user.
It's San Francisco players.
But I would definitely have recommended that.
And when I went to see it,
uh,
king of the Hughes,
I sat there thinking,
how was this play ever done anywhere?
But in San Francisco,
the resonance was so strong.
The,
the,
the places that she mentioned is that the locations,
the things that we all know or that many of us know,
whether you know,
that we draw from our own childhood experiences are,
um,
are really,
uh,
strong and they're much stronger.
You know,
this play has been done king of the ease and the great leap had been done all
over the country.
Yes.
But there's something really special about seeing San Francisco productions
about it.
They're going to be rare.
It's a rare opportunity.
But the one thing that I think you might've noticed so that the audience is kind
of like,
they just get such a kick out of hearing about things that they know and that's
not an experience you can have that often.
And I think one of the things that are regional theater does when it's being
successful is kind of connecting to the community in a way that this play a
local playwright and a local actor,
Kevin,
help them do.
Yes,
I would agree.
And it's even more special when the audience can really relate and visually see
the locations.
I mean in the great leap,
it's USF,
it's Chinatown.
Galileo high school is also mentioned and so they're already along the ride for
you.
There's not,
I mean you obviously have to work for the story,
but it's kind of Nice when they're already with you when they're already,
yes.
Okay.
Absolutely.
And I had the really good experience of doing the same play in New York last
year and one of the major joy is of doing it again here is my seeing the
difference of how the audience reacts to certain things.
And I love the way the San Francisco audience response to the San Francisco
office of the play.
It's,
you can feel it and you can hear it in it's,
it's really exciting.
There's a line in the play where the d,
The American basketball coaches telling the kid,
you know,
I played,
I went to China and I and I coached the Chinese basketball players and they
don't want to like,
you know,
rough each other up and they don't want to,
they don't want to touch each other.
This,
I'm paraphrasing,
but that's what he says.
And the kid says,
ah,
have you ever been to Chinatown?
And that line is a ferry.
Perfectly funny line in New York City,
but in San Francisco,
the audience just loves it.
They just love knowing that the playwright really knows what yes,
pushy Chinese people in China town hall on the 30 stocks in our life.
So true.
So,
so true.
And you mentioned you did this play in New York and so this is the second time
around.
What does it like to play the character for the second time?
It's great.
I um,
the Ma,
whenever you do a play in a different theater,
it's going to be different.
But this is even more so different than that because it's a completely different
theater company that did the play.
It was completely weird for director and different actors.
So I'm the real only kind of consistent thing in it.
So,
um,
and the other big difference is that the theater was very small in,
in New York.
It was a 99 seat theater and this is an 1100 seat theater and just technique
wise and um,
uh,
physically it's a completely different production is a big set.
Is this,
this version is much more like a Broadway show,
right?
Then the one we did in New York where Broadway is.
So that experience is really,
um,
a learning experience for somebody like me because you're always surprised at
the news,
things that you can discover when,
when the play is opened up in a much bigger way.
Right.
Lots of things.
Like,
like there's,
I have more costumes in this production than I had in the first production.
And,
and usually you'd think,
uh,
the play,
the storytelling of the play requires certain characters to wear certain
costumes at certain times.
And that's true.
But I was able to,
because of the theater was so small where the same thing throughout the entire
play and it worked really well because that character was consistent throughout
from 1971 to 1989 this time because it's so opened up in big,
when I walk off the stage and I come back on again and it's a different time
period.
You kind of want to see me dressed differently.
Yeah.
And so why I was really kind of thrown off at present President,
Oh,
I'm gonna wear all these like met the first day.
They show you all the sketches and stuff.
And I was really surprised at that.
And then I,
my mind had to click over to,
oh,
I see,
I see this differently now.
And that is an example of a lot of different things that have happened,
the way you use your voice and all of that stuff.
Um,
that,
that are adjustments and,
and learning experiences.
How has it been just performing for some of the early audiences?
I saw it during a dress rehearsals.
I know that was the first time.
Yeah.
Uh,
well,
um,
the,
uh,
play like this with a lot of fast language and a lot of,
um,
of,
you know,
one at least one of the four characters and the plate that has a lot of
movement,
um,
and a lot of staging.
And then there's physical elements in the production,
like moving scenery and stuff like that.
These things take such time to iron out.
And so there's never been such a thing as,
as,
as a perfectly brilliant dress rehearsal because you're still working things
out.
You can never be bad ahead of schedule that by the time the audience comes,
it's all down.
Yeah.
You're still,
your mind is always processing things.
So we did a pretty clean skate on,
on,
um,
bat dress rehearsal,
but the show has definitely deepened and deepened to deepen and we'd done it
maybe six or seven times now.
And it's,
it's almost,
it's pretty much hit its stride as far as the command that we have over it.
Right.
And it's like practicing anything right over and over again.
The more you do it,
the better it gets.
And,
and,
and with this kind of play,
which is kind of deep and kind of full of lots of details and stuff.
Yeah.
It's,
it's a kind of a,
um,
a bottomless,
well,
you know,
you don't,
you don't ever get bored of it because there's always something new to discover.
Yeah.
Got It.
That's the beauty of,
of theater I've,
yeah.
And good plays and the plays that are written with a,
some kind of substance or see when you're in love with the play too.
Yeah,
I do it all the time.
I do.
And this particular play is one of the,
uh,
one of my favorite place that I've ever been able to do.
I love doing it.
I could keep doing it forever.
I understand why actors like Carol Channing and Yule Brenner played parts
forever and ever.
I used to think they were losers.
I used to think,
Oh God,
put it away,
Carol,
you're 80 years old and she's going on tour with another tour of Hello Dolly.
She maybe did seven and real yule Brenner and seven or eight tours of,
of,
but when that part things for you,
you want to keep doing it and you know what you're giving the audience and
they're loving it,
there's no way that you're going to give that up.
So I don't see myself continuing to do this play the like 80,
but I understand.
I understand the joy that one gets from that.
Yeah.
I mean,
you could certainly do it because at that age progression and you certainly
don't age and awesome.
Yeah.
Okay.
Well,
I really walked away with from the play was that it's about manifesting destiny
and you know,
there's two characters,
um,
and one is able to just kind of move through the world and say,
yes,
everything is on my plate and I can grab it.
That's Manford and for your character,
it's more or less like waiting for the opportunity to be told like it's now your
time and there's a line at the end where he,
and I'm gonna paraphrase as well,
but like basically saying that,
you know,
I didn't know that it was my time,
but now it's my time.
It's always been there.
Yeah.
And I'm wondering how that parallels with your successful career that you've
had.
Wow.
I never made a penny.
I never thought it to parallel it,
that particularly personally,
I have always considered him someone that I needed to learn about because he
being,
a citizen of Communist China.
Yeah.
You know,
what was built into that life as p particularly yet this in this time period was
a life of giving yourself,
giving over your own wishes to the wishes of the party and not,
I'm making choices for yourself.
And what's a nice juxtaposition and the play is that this,
this,
this balls to the wall Asian American kid who doesn't know anything about that
just once and,
and you know,
is,
is going after his,
his dream.
Yes.
And,
um,
in,
in comparison to this other character in China is,
um,
giving up all of his dreams because he,
he,
there's no,
there's no alternative for him because of the political circumstances that he is
in.
Personally,
I,
I guess what I can say is that when I was in high school,
I was just so lucky to have had a berry mentor relationship with a high school
drama teacher who recognize potential in me and who absolutely demanded
that I
follow with or that I do not squander it to the point where she like took me by
the hand to my own parents and said,
you know,
I really think this person needs to,
uh,
keep doing this.
Wow.
And my parents were rather typical Asian American,
second generation parents.
They weren't super,
super,
they weren't tiger parents.
They were more though,
um,
condition down,
uh,
assumed that the best thing for us would be successful and stable careers,
doctor or lawyer.
That was it,
right?
Yes.
And,
and,
and so that was a huge paradigm shift for this person who was kind of an expert.
Right.
She knew she was a drama teacher.
Not really,
but she did go,
I have credibility for my parents.
And so,
so the,
the idea,
when you say the idea of taking your shot or looking following your bliss or
taking what you think is could be yours that came from outside forces that I was
lucky to have been exposed to.
Um,
and I guess I do relate emotionally at the end of the play to someone who isn't
able to do that.
Yeah.
And,
and the,
the,
the whatever,
the complicated feelings that one has,
not having to have that restriction,
the guilt you might feel,
survivors guilt kind of thing.
Or what if it were me,
you know,
we know really we're all here just because we're here where we don't get a
choice to be communist Chinese or not coming as Johnny's,
you know,
and in this particular plate really shows that you don't have a choice.
Yes.
And,
and so I don't,
you know,
I think we all kind of take for granted our freedom and our ability to do
whatever we want and to say whatever we want.
And the play kind of,
um,
very,
very uh,
beautifully kind of reminds us of that.
And I do like that part about the play.
So I do relate to the characters inability to access his dreams based upon my
ability to access my dreams I guess.
Yes.
It's interesting because
a lot of times,
you know,
even like if we take the context out of the play of just being maybe an emerging
artist of color or part of the Lgbtq community,
which you have been a huge advocate for both.
Um,
I think it's quite difficult when we are going out to pursue those kinds of
artistic dreams,
whether it be an acting dance or even here in text.
If you don't see a role model,
it's hard to really think about can I go out and like grab hold of those dreams.
And it was great that you mentioned your high school mentor,
but you know,
as someone who may not have that,
what is some advice that you would,
well,
I may be advice.
I have tons of advice.
We put the floor,
I give advice.
I think it's in,
and it is important to acknowledge that phenomenon of um,
uh,
representation.
I mean we,
uh,
we were at the point now where we're talking about representation all the time.
Yeah.
It doesn't lose its meaning,
but,
but what would I love to talk about?
What is absolutely essential about that representation is the influence that
that represents a change and has over younger people.
Yes.
Right.
And that what we're really fighting for in our grown up state is what?
Well,
we want to see more Asians.
I want to see my,
I want my stories to be told.
I want to see sexy Asian people on the screen and all of that stuff.
But what we really want is for the needle to,
to shift because the,
because our kids don't have the,
the same street,
the same schism when it comes to looking,
searching fruitlessly for themselves in the media.
And it's,
it is shifting in a way where the exposure is greater now.
And we do that.
And so my advice would be,
I don't know what,
you know,
I don't,
I,
I think it's,
it's partly,
for me,
it's always been kind of that Cokie Gandhi thing that be the change you want to
see thing.
You know,
that,
that there's always someone that you can mentor.
There's always somebody,
even if you're not famous,
there's always someone that is looking to you for,
and we as role models,
I think people forget that,
that,
that thing is really happening.
You don't see it happening.
You don't feel it happening,
but it's happening.
Yeah.
He,
young people are looking to you for an example of what it is,
is they are going to be,
they have no other frame of reference,
but to see a person older and more experienced than them and to do as they do.
Yes.
And to,
and so our self esteem is super important.
And our sense of sorting out all the baggage that our parents gave us and their
grandparents gave them sorting all that so that it's a little bit easier for
them is a fun challenge I think because we're still dealing with our own
baggage.
But I think we do have less a little bit then we'd been,
our grandparents had,
I hope so.
We have different kinds.
Our grandparents didn't care about representation,
you know,
they don't care at all about,
um,
but then I do remember my,
my parent's generation of people running into the,
into the living room saying,
oh my God,
look,
there's an Asian person on TV.
Like that kind of thing.
And that's all running into the,
the,
the living room,
dude,
that wasn't that long ago.
And,
and there's still a sense of that now.
Right?
Oh look.
Wow.
It's a commercial with an Asian person in it.
So that's kind of a new trend.
Yeah.
Commercials of Asian people in them.
Um,
well,
because for whatever reason,
we can talk about it forever about the,
the misnomer that Asian people,
their money doesn't matter or something like that.
Okay.
So now it's clearly true that it's been,
it's been established that the money does matter and that's a good for us in a
way,
and it's certainly good for our representation.
Oh,
totally.
Yeah.
And I mean,
the success with crazy rich Asians,
I mean,
yeah.
Pretty is that it can be right,
right.
That it transcended it being an Asian movie by being popular across the board.
Right?
Yeah.
Yes.
And that's what's really nice.
Uh,
I did hear it on a podcast that you did maybe a couple of weeks ago with Kq ed.
Um,
what really struck me was you did talk about the responsibility that you have or
producers or people who have that power of choosing story,
that they have this,
um,
responsibility to create these images and characters so that yet the younger
generation can,
you know,
yeah.
Be inspired.
So I'm wondering like,
what is,
is your personal responsibility for that?
Are you having a hand in developing?
Oh,
yeah.
Even when am I doing?
Yeah,
I do.
I am.
I,
I think that's one of the great,
one of the things that comes out of frustration is the,
is the creative limitations that you're given,
create,
uh,
if you're,
if you're up for it,
uh,
opportunities for yourself or for others or for the people that you believe in
that are experiencing the same kind of marginalization as you.
And,
and so I have,
I'm always working on things on my own,
like trying to kind of maintain my relationship with theaters,
like act to kind of like,
I'm already kind of thinking now what's next?
What would I do here next?
And,
and kind of coming up with,
you can't just pick one thing.
You can't just go to Pam McKinney,
the artistic director and say,
Oh,
here's the one thing I want to do.
Do it.
You have to kind of give her kind of a landscape of things that might work and
see whether any of them appeal,
appeal to her and,
and all,
all of those things for me in evolve,
um,
Asian Americans or,
uh,
you know,
not just me or me as a character playing,
they're all explorations of reimagination of classic work or new work itself
that will do what this play that we're doing now is doing.
Um,
and when I talk about producers,
I'm not exactly sure exactly what I said that time,
but,
or don't remember exactly,
but I do feel that there's this phenomenon that we're all kind of well aware of
that's very frustrating that we don't know what to do about it.
And that is that things that unless it affects you,
you often don't want to do anything about something.
It's the kind of thing,
you know,
to use a very,
um,
brutal example.
It's like the people that are most championing cancer research and stuff are
people that cancer has touched themselves.
Right?
And this is,
this is the,
this is a kind of way in some ways for people to choose the things that mean
most to them,
which is a nice thing.
However,
when it comes to Hollywood that the issue of diversity doesn't ring true for a
lot of people and it kind of defines white privilege,
what might,
what we like to throw around this term love white privilege because a person has
no sense of what that damage or what that pain or what that exclusion feels
like.
So they're the ones who are doing it,
are doing it cause they know they're supposed to or whatever.
So it some way to get them to feel.
That is the thing that I think is,
is an interesting challenge to get them to understand,
to take to heart.
Um,
um,
it's the equivalent of,
of going to a cancer benefit and,
and like a big cancer gala or something and watching the video that they show of
what it means to us survivor or to their family or whatever and you're going,
oh,
those are human beings.
I relate to being a human being.
That thing,
I don't have to have cancer to know that this is important and that kind of
sharing of that because there are still so many producers and people that better
borderline,
they're either doing it because they think they're supposed to and that's good,
but there's still not really feeling it or they don't get it at all.
It doesn't occur to them.
And,
and I'm fascinated by that because I personally am really,
um,
I don't consume a lot of things that are all white.
Like I,
when I see something that seems to kind of like it's all white or not,
doesn't have any Asian people in it at all.
I'm not as interested.
I don't connect to it.
I mean,
I,
um,
and so,
uh,
like,
like I watched the other day,
I watched hidden figures,
which everybody loves that movie.
Right?
It's a great,
it's very satisfying movie.
But I've,
I'm,
I'm less moved by it.
I feel left out of it in some ways because as we grew,
as we,
as I've grown up,
it was always like,
are you black or white?
There was a,
like a kind of question that that was a very strange one to proceed.
People asking anyway.
I don't know.
That's just me going on about that.
I love it.
Okay,
thanks.
It's very interesting,
but I,
I kind of want to tag back onto what you just said about,
well,
I'm not a part of it and I think that's kind of the narrative that a lot of
Asian Americans feel that were not part of the main narrative in Hollywood.
Right.
Um,
Kinda to tie it back to Lauren and then,
yeah,
I know we're talking about the great leap,
but the king of the,
he's made a comment about,
um,
you know,
in marketing,
there's the black people marketing the,
his attention,
right?
And then there's Asians and we're all lumped into the Caucasian marketing plan,
which I thought was a very interesting point.
Um,
and I'm wondering how do we get more visibility out there?
Like,
how do we like raise our voices and say,
Hey,
we mad or,
or,
you know,
make more stories about us because we want to watch it?
Well,
I would tie that into my being here today really,
because what I'm trying to do,
I mean the theater wants me to come and talk about the show,
which is great and I love talking about the show.
But what I really want to do is to create a situation in which Asian people are
really supporting their own content.
Because the only way to perpetuate that content is sports us be successful.
Yes.
And,
and if Pam Mckinnon the,
the,
uh,
Caucasian American artistic director of American Conservatory Theater has a big
dud with this play,
she's less likely to do another one and then we're all more likely to complain
about it.
And we're like,
oh,
well they act.
They don't ever do well.
Did you go?
Did you go see?
Yeah,
exactly.
And,
and,
and for Asian American people,
with a lot of people like human beings,
they don't always understand the gesture of that,
like doing your part voting,
um,
all of that stuff.
You know,
like,
yes,
it does matter that you vote.
And yes,
it does matter that you buy a ticket to see a play if you care about what the
play can do for you,
you know,
the things that you're complaining about w we all complain about.
Um,
so that's an equation that I think could be more made,
more clear and,
and I love that and I always try to tell people,
oh,
just
try to support the content because the co,
and we really did that in a big way with crazy with Jay.
That was really super gratifying to me and reassuring to me and encouraging to
me that this generation of,
of Asian Americans put their money where their mouth was and created a sense
whether it's true or not,
that's something has changed.
You know,
because there's a lot of articles out there now saying hasn't really changed or
whatever is it,
what will happen next?
There's a fair amount of crazy rich Asian knock off action happening out there,
which is a really good sign that,
that um,
you know,
I'm not into knockoffs but I'm into the representation so I'll take it.
But it's absolutely like there's going to be a couple of television shows and
all of that stuff.
And um,
that's really good.
You do have to kind of,
in some ways,
if you're really,
really responsible,
you take note of the people that are sponsoring Asian content and try to kind of
support them.
That's what network television is kind of.
Um,
one thing that it allows you to do is to see the corporations and the companies
that support the things that we're trying to do.
So we don't think about that.
Right.
I don't think about it that much.
I have to go,
okay.
Oh look,
So these people are sponsors of the,
the whatever show,
you know,
I don't know,
whatever it is,
you know,
I'm doing this comedy central show with Aquafina in the summer and,
and I can't wait to see who,
who buys add time on that show.
Okay.
Last question.
I'd love to know what your mom thinks about all of this because moms are
important.
Yes.
Because we are at the Asian affinity Google Group,
aren't we?
You know,
really,
I have to say,
I still,
I consider my mother way more than I should in various everyday decisions like
buying underwear.
I just,
so it's so deeply ingrained to me to please her that,
that I,
that I think about her and to a fault and it's not good necessarily,
not necessarily good for me sometimes,
but I do do it and there are really positive side effects of that.
And I must say that choosing this play to do it here and to do it here now and
to kind of kind of drop everything at like as much as I could to do it because
the time commitment that it takes to do a play is really intense.
And that means being away from home and I have a teenage son and all of that
stuff.
So choosing to do so,
uh,
to do a play out of town was made infinitely more seductive,
was satisfying because my mom's here and because my mom is,
you know,
inviting our,
my whole family,
my whole gigantic,
her whole family who mostly are still in the bay area to come to the matinee on
Sunday this Sunday and then have this big party and up stairs in the theater and
do that kind of thing.
You know,
cause she is like,
she,
there's no,
there isn't one.
There isn't one prototypical uh,
Chinese mom.
But there were maybe four or five.
Yes.
And my mom is the one who will do,
will do anything,
not to brag,
um,
by using bragging words.
Ah,
if you look closely,
there's a lot of bragging going on,
but it's very classy and it's Barry,
she never says anything.
She lets everyone else say nice things and then she says she just nods or
something like that.
You must be very proud.
Yeah.
So she is,
is,
is in,
in that kind of,
it's kind of passive aggressive,
you know,
kind of like she's,
she doesn't want to shoot,
but,
but it's wonderful to be the beneficiary or the recipient or the inspiration for
her doing these things.
Yeah.
Inviting all the,
her,
her family and friends to Biz thing and,
and not pushing them to come see it,
but telling them when it is and,
and hoping that they come and then feeding them.
That's key.
Yeah.
That's,
yeah.
It's cute.
Yeah.
Um,
and um,
uh,
she's kind of a mascot of the production because the last time I worked at act,
she kind of cozied up to the house staff.
And so then she would say to me,
Oh,
I'm going to go shopping and Chinatown.
Oh God,
I think I'm going to come and see the second act of the play and just show up.
And they'd be like,
let her sit in the back or whatever like that.
I said,
well,
you can't just show up.
I mean that you have to like meet the person or what.
But she is,
she's treated very royal Lee and it's very nice.
It's very just like the [inaudible] tower juror.
And she's very cute and,
um,
and,
and she's very,
she has a very lovable personality.
She really does.
She,
she just like were,
you know,
she's very infectious and very kind of smiley.
I love that.
Yeah.
That's great.
Thank you.
Bd.
Sure.
We have our first question over here.
Okay.
You're on Abd.
Hey.
Um,
I'm also,
I noticed that you're a native San Franciscan.
I know we've talked a
lot of serious topics,
but we wanted to talk about some of the fun,
Julian mentioned food talks.
Ah,
and I'm,
you know,
I'm always curious about when actors kind of come home,
at least back to San Francisco or actresses,
you know,
what's your,
what's your go to,
what is the one thing when you come back here that you need to have that kind of
connects you back with your childhood and some of these good joyous memories?
Uh,
capitol restaurant,
Clay Street,
chicken wings,
they're famous chicken wings.
And they're,
I mean,
like,
I,
I'm,
I'm almost kind of like,
you almost kind of want to not tell people about them because you want them for
yourself.
Um,
but that comes to mind immediately.
My family is obsessed with the house of primary hub on bad ass obsessed.
And we go there.
We like,
I mean,
at the like opening of an off below,
we will go there.
It's like we will go there for any occasion.
Well,
we'll make up some special occasion and goes
and um,
of like,
uh,
so we do the high slot primary whenever we can.
We just did it a couple of weeks ago.
Um,
let's see,
what else is there a sunset bakery,
chaucey bowels
that's on like ninth avenue and Irving,
um,
or Judah.
And,
um,
let's see what else?
Let's see.
I'm going through all of my ethnic groups,
Mexican,
um,
you know,
my uncle Bobby,
my mom's brother,
uh,
replicated the retina.
You guys are mostly too young for this,
but,
but my uncle Bobby replicated the recipe of the enchiladas at this place called
the hot house,
which was,
um,
at playland at the beach,
which was by the cliff house.
This like boardwalk.
They used to be there and there used to be this like a pass through window rest
car title precursor to a food truck kind of restaurant called the hot house.
And they had these very basic but delicious kind of,
um,
uh,
enchiladas that came in,
a little cardboard tray and he might,
so my uncle has kept that recipe alive and it makes that a big batch of this,
this Enchilada gravy that they made.
And so that's a childhood memory of going to the hot house at the beach.
Cause I grew up on 40th and Ortega.
I'm really close to the beach.
Um,
those are the hot top five,
I think the ones that come to mind.
Then there'll be more that come to mind and I'll,
I'll blurt them out like Tourette's.
Sweet.
Thank you.
Sure.
Okay.
Right over here.
Thanks again for coming today.
VD.
Sure.
Um,
this is a little bit more of a personal question.
So I went to acting school in New York many years ago.
Uh,
when I graduated it was the early aughts and I walked into an industry that,
uh,
was not particularly looking for dudes who look like me and I wanted to talk,
you talked a lot about representation to yeah,
I wanted to talk a little bit more about,
um,
the pipeline issue and,
and for me,
I got out of the game and I'm very keen to admit that.
And um,
it was really hard for me,
but I,
I,
I had those prototypical parents who were like,
chase your dream,
chase your dream.
And then it became,
I can't do this anymore.
So I,
I guess my question is,
what would you say to all of the folks who now are going into an industry that
is just slightly more friendly to folks like us to keep them in the game and to
keep that
Oh,
great.
That is a really good positive based question.
Thank you.
And we visit the good things come from pain.
And if that,
if you're a pain created this question and changes somebody's life,
that's probably a good thing.
But I will say that just before I answer is that that pain,
that rejection and that shame are universal right there.
They're not your own.
And you know,
you have to blame really the situation much more than yourself for that,
that outcome of that.
Um,
you seem perfectly happy now.
So I'm,
I'm,
I trust that,
that we'll see.
Yeah.
Um,
and what I would say,
well I would,
I wouldn't say anything that's that different from what people told me when I
first started,
when it was considerably different,
which was if you absolutely have to do it,
then do it.
And if you don't,
you should think of something else.
It's super difficult.
It's,
it messes with your mind.
It messes with your self esteem and messes with your sense of self worth,
your sense of what success means.
And,
um,
you have to be,
you have to have a extremely strong constitution and an extremely accessible
support system.
And I feel like you're right that,
that the needle's moved to the point where young people,
you know,
you want to kind of slap them for the things that they complain about.
Right.
Um,
because it was so much harder before and it is so much,
there's so much more opportunity now.
But with that opportunity comes more competition and,
and I certainly feel that from the beginning of my career there was less
competition and the competition has grown and the amount of younger people in
the industry has grown,
blah,
but so also has the amount of Asian American writers and the amount of producers
and people that are actually making an influential choices.
So I would just say that they really should not take for granted,
especially given what you're saying,
they should not take for granted any progress that's being made.
But you know,
young people are so clueless sometimes,
right?
Because we,
and,
and rightly so because we can't know anything that happened before us.
We can hear about it and we can take it to heart.
When,
when,
when my,
when we talked to my son who was born in 2000 about nine 11 he understands the
gravity of it.
He doesn't feel the emotion of it.
He's,
he wasn't there to watch on television.
The absolute devastation and the loss and the emotional feelings.
So if you guys know that this show come from a way came into town a few weeks
ago,
come from away,
it's about a nine old centered around the day of nine 11 and the days after.
And it's one thing where if you're of a certain age and you're sitting in the
audience of that show,
everyone in the audience is having the same emotional experience,
which is a very rare thing.
You,
you,
you can't in in Lawrence play,
she's having to explain certain really heavy things that have happened in
history and you get it from understanding what she's taught you about.
It come from away starts and it says today's nine 11 and everyone starts crying
immediately and it's kind of great.
Anybody born after nine 11 it doesn't really understand.
This is a tangent to try to describe that these,
these,
these rather adorable young people that are becoming actors don't really
understand the,
the things that were built on the backs of other people.
Right?
This is an ongoing discussion about everything,
about aids,
about gay people and the aids and about the Holocaust and everything.
Everything major that has ever happened where every pain that any generation has
experienced,
it's really hard to,
to for the following generation to feel.
So we cut them a little bit of slack and we tried to kind of,
um,
uh,
for me I think a sense of discipline and a sense of entitlement,
um,
uh,
a discipline needs to be encouraged and entitlement needs to be kind of,
you know,
smacked out of people sometime and,
and so,
but,
but the advice I would give is that it requires an absolutely,
um,
steadfast constitution and that there's great joy to be had in it and that,
that there's something actually kind of noble about it.
There is a sense that I learned from my first acting teacher that you are a
messenger and that if the messages that you're giving are true and are positive
and they make people think where they make people act differently than you've
done something where you've acted as an agent to something actually happening.
So it's not just kind of glamor and kind of,
um,
acting and applause and stuff like that.
It could be rather useful in society.
So thank you.
I appreciate that.
Thank you.
Okay.
Thanks again for coming out.
Um,
just wanted to ask you a question.
As an Asian American who's also grown up with like second generation parents,
um,
you know,
if you ever traveled back to China and if and when you did,
did you,
how
was that experience for you and you know,
how,
how were you able to channel that when you were,
um,
you know,
acting during the play?
I went to China on one,
two major times on the first time I went.
Um,
my dad was still alive and I was booked to be the guest speaker on a cruise that
went to China.
And it was a super duper,
hilariously fancy cruise with all super old white people.
But I was supposed to talk about being Chinese person to them.
I was like,
it was a little bit like a zoo.
No,
it's like,
oh,
competing time is at four 15 BD Wong will come out and you can
row pretzels at him.
But it wasn't really,
really many ways moving experience.
My Dad had not been back to Hong Kong since he wa he left Hong Kong.
My Dad,
my,
oddly enough,
my grandfather was born in California.
My grandfather went back home to marry my grandma and to have my dad and then
brought them back.
So my dad was technically not bought,
brought born here,
but he was born a citizen.
Um,
and,
and so he had this very like,
oh my gosh,
this is where I was born,
kind of thing that he w that really snuck up on him.
He,
I don't think he ever even thought about going back,
but he was this opportunity.
We went back.
So that was that.
And,
um,
uh,
there's just,
I wish I could talk for an hour about this cruise.
It was,
it was so funny because,
well,
first of all,
I will tell you that the one thing is it was so fancy that they,
they give you this little thing to fill out when you come in,
when you check into your room and the thing to asks you what kind of liquor they
want you to stock,
um,
the bar with the refrigerator with,
okay.
And you get four bottles of each or something like that.
And my mom is a white wine drinker and my dad was a Jack Daniel's drinker,
so they got four bottles of white wine and four bottles of Jack Daniels.
And then that night they put all eight bottles in their suitcase.
They filled out the form again,
by the end of the cruise,
they had like a bevmo in under the bed.
I don't want to say,
you know,
it's racial profiling to say that this is because they're Chinese,
but you know,
no pun intended it,
you do the math.
Um,
I,
I went on a second trip to China in 2003 to make a terrible television movie,
but I,
that was a really interesting cultural experience for me as well,
working with Chinese people and working in the Chinese film industry in rural
China.
And I think really,
you know,
I hope you'll come see the play.
Lauren talks about the experience of being an Asian American and going to China
as a very unique kind of odd fish out of water experience.
And that is an experience I felt.
I didn't really feel like I was home or anything like that.
Um,
I felt it,
it's so obvious to them that you're American before you even open your mouth.
They just,
you can,
you just,
you can't hide it.
And so there's always a kind of either a curiosity or a slight stain over you.
And,
and so I felt that tension and that was no different than the way that,
uh,
the,
the young woman and the play describes it in and in Lauren's play.
So apparently Laura and understands that kind of experience too.
It's pretty common.
Um,
did I answer the question?
Not really.
You did or
you said good things,
but you did not answer the question.
How we learned about the Bevmo w what was the,
what was the specific question?
I can answer it now,
I guess.
Oh,
how do I draw on it for the play?
Well,
I would say that,
um,
uh,
how did I draw on it for what I did really,
really related to Lauren's words about being an Asian American,
going to China.
And I think what I had to do really the research about how shut down at a
Chinese person who's,
um,
not a,
not a dream seeker,
you know,
a person who was sort of a certain constitution who is a party member of the,
uh,
you know,
a member of the party and very obedient and very diligent what there that is a
very different kind of person than me.
And,
and so I did have to kind of access whatever else I feel in my life that shuts
me down or,
uh,
quiets me or keeps me from making decisions.
And I do do relate to feeling like when I like a younger man being closeted and
feeling kind of restricted by my sense of being closeted and a sense of not
being able to be free and open and,
and,
and speak my own truth.
So that's the thing I would relate to I think more than going to China actually.
Thank you.
Sure.
I'm just going back and forth because it makes sense.
Awesome.
Um,
so I think a lot about inequity.
It's very heavy topic.
Yes.
I think a lot about inequity.
Um,
in one thing I've been thinking a lot about is the importance of Asian Americans
need to leverage their privilege in order to stand in deep solidarity with other
communities of color.
So black and brown communities.
And I know obviously there's a nuance in various industries,
you know,
I think the tech industry,
we're highly represented here and that looks different than other places.
But I wanted to hear a little bit more from you around how you think about Asian
Americans building that solidarity with other communities of Color in the
entertainment industry and what you see happening on that front.
It's a such a wide reaching far reaching industry,
right?
You have Hollywood and here we are.
I'm working at an an regional theater and the regional theater has its own
agenda and aspirations for community building and for community fundraising and
all of that stuff.
And they're different.
I think the,
the,
the wider,
um,
Hollywood industry is driven by a kind of bottom line kind of thing that makes
it really hard for,
um,
this,
these,
this needle to shift.
And I don't know if actually this,
this might be a similar kind of tangent,
but what your question is reminding me of is my own baggage about fundraising.
Like,
for example,
when I'm,
I'm pushing up the mountain,
several of my own projects,
I've co written a musical that I'm trying to,
uh,
to,
to continue to develop.
And I have say,
uh,
several,
several other projects,
a lot of theater projects,
and I find myself,
uh,
um,
one of them is one that our friend is,
has been involved in who,
a mutual friend who,
which is a very diverse cast of,
of actors and other projects are Asian American projects.
And I find myself trying to edit myself when it comes to whose money I'm going
after.
Like I,
I found like,
oh,
you can't ask an Asian American person to help me find that the diverse project
you should really be getting to Asian American person to fund the Asian American
project.
But I think,
well,
wait a second though,
but I'm the Asian American making this project,
will that be enough for them to support me to help move the needle in that way?
Because my work as a,
as a writer will be,
uh,
put on the map and then,
um,
I will be able to have the credibility to create more and more content.
And is it,
as it turns out,
this particular diverse project ends up having a lot of Asian people in it,
but it's not an Asian project.
And so is there a kind of what I'm saying is that I perceive there to be some
kind of invisible,
um,
limit to the amount of support I can get from the Asian American community,
like from Asian people that have money,
I think,
oh,
I have to be really careful about who I ask money for and what it's for.
Bail.
They'll want me to just,
they'll want me to just do all Asian content I think.
And so that's interesting because I guess when I,
as I'm repeating it,
I'm an Asian American artist and that's the,
um,
the content that I'm generating.
But I know that doesn't really specifically answer your question.
I'm also just me and I don't really understand or know what's going on out there
necessarily about the connections between different groups.
And how,
um,
you know,
Ken savage who was up here before,
um,
no.
Was He up here yet?
No,
he wasn't a pure yet.
Ken Savage who works at act and brought me here today is,
um,
with talking about how,
hey ha he has been in this building before because he also did a Google talk
with the,
um,
uh,
the black Google live groups.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And,
and so that shows you that,
that kind of accessing the different groups within the theater,
the theater,
the theater is an active thing that's happening.
Um,
uh,
but I think you're absolutely right.
That's kind of solidarity is really helpful.
I think everybody has their own kind of agenda and their own kind of unique
challenges and that sometimes makes things difficult as you can imagine.
Yeah.
Thank you so much for questions.
Sure.
We are out of time.
Really.
Yeah,
I know.
It's been so much fun.
I'm sorry for those who couldn't ask the questions.
Um,
but,
but I just want to thank you so much for being here today,
and for those who don't have,
please go watch a show.
It's running at AACT.
Gary stage the great leap until March 31st so thank you again.
Okay.